this is a Fox News weather alert
hurricane ARMA the strongest hurricane
ever recorded in the Atlantic currently
wreaking havoc in the Caribbean with the
storm forecasted to hit the United
States mainland in the coming days we're
monitoring the storm and we'll have a
full update later in the hour now for
our top story yesterday we told you
about President Trump's announcement
that he's ending President Obama's
controversial daca program which helped
illegal immigrants brought to the US as
children although even many liberal
legal analysts agree daca is on shaky
legal authority the media is attacking
President Trump is heartless and
motivated by an animus towards Latinos
the president's decision to end daca was
heartless and it was brainless if this
order stands hundreds hundreds of
thousands of families will be ripped
apart this is one of the most cruel acts
we've seen in the presidents in a long
time and it's it the President Obama and
President Trump not only disagree on
policies they disagree on values it's
hard for me to see the big picture from
a Republican point of view Joe going
forward and just giving the back of your
hand to people who have Hispanic
surnames this whole gaslighting that's
come to so many issues especially racial
issues in this country
it's so obvious not even a dog whistle
anymore it's just flat-out bias flat-out
discrimination that they're touting
coming from this White House so this is
racist repealing Obama care is racist
the travel ban was racist even Trump's
speech in Poland was racist Greg when
they don't have a policy argument to
make it's the racial attack is that
right it's the most overused quiver that
they have you know all Trump did it is
he made it legal he put a ring on it and
I think about I mean think about it he
put it in the right place it was in the
wrong place
you know how delicious cookies are I
love cookies remember them but I don't
have the cookie jar in the bathroom next
to the toilet I keep it in the kitchen
what he did was he took
something that should be in the Congress
in the Congress he moved it into the
right place that's all he did he made
the public part of the decision which is
what should have been done in both sides
actually agree that this is where it
should be he transferred the decision
not the dreamer the dreamers are going
to stay where they are
it's where the decision is going you
know what this reminds me of it reminds
me of the Reagan when Reagan I announced
the registering of the draft I think I
was in well I don't know what year I was
in high school or something and
everybody got angry oh my god he's
Hitler he's terrible but he it was
necessary and it didn't change a thing
it was just something that he felt he
had to do because it was the legal right
thing to do but it didn't change a thing
this if the media actually reported the
story they'd have nothing so the
president is heartless and racist for
following the Constitution that is what
the left is arguing right well and
remember what my theory is that racism
is greater than Russia so that if they
have a chance to say that a Republican
is racist they will take it almost every
time so this this is something
Republicans deal with a lot I do think
that there's something to be said that
if President Trump had just waited three
weeks when one of the courts was going
to strike this down then he could have
said okay well I guess can't defend it
and then ask the Congress to do it then
he probably would have had to deal with
all of this but remember this pleased
his base for a day and then by the end
of the night everybody on that TV that
you just saw that was complaining
actually the president agrees with you
he said he wants Daka to get done he
wants it he wants to sign it into law
and if it's not it's okay because he'll
revisit it then because nobody has to
worry about anything so I don't
understand why the right isn't more mad
right because it seems like the the left
is angry when in fact the president
agrees with many people on the left that
the dreamers should be protected and
they should find some sort of legal
status permanently and that's the point
was the executive order didn't codify
their immigration status it really
didn't it wasn't a long-term stable form
of protection
and as Gregg pointed out at the
beginning of the show last night that's
it made the whole thing so cool and it's
very interesting because Danny you're
absolutely right about race in the
Republican Party because any chance that
opponents get they will they will pin
the racist tail on the elephant and and
that's why there were so many
Republicans who came out and so strongly
admonished the president for his
careless comments after Charlotte's
ville because it's such a sensitive
issue particularly a lot of the
lawmakers from the South for whom it is
an ongoing issue from their childhood
and you know their ancestry but having
said that the president wants dock of
the past and I think that shows that we
do have some complex issues in
immigration a lot of people want the
wall most people vast majority of people
want the dreamers to be able to stay
here if they were brought here against
their will and all they know is a great
American life for majority of them one
I'm going to hit you with a theoretical
argument about illegal immigration and
just tell me if you think I'm wrong here
okay so if you're a white guy and you
live in Texas and you cross the border
into Mexico illegally and you go down
there for a few years and you're working
cash jobs and you're driving without
insurance and you know you're not paying
any taxes and things like that then the
Mexican authorities catch you and they
send you back to the United States does
that mean and cruel and racist against
white people or is that just Mexico
following the law I think it's Mexico
found a lot why when the United States
does that to Mexicans it's racist and
cruel you know I love these because it's
such false analogy it was a perfect
analogy
I get a 9-point the Russian judge gives
a 97 on the analogy yeah it's a Russian
judge though the whole issue heal us
without harm the whole issue though is I
think you know that you have a president
who I think is very vulnerable to
charges about racial bias given what
happened after Charles feel given what
happened as we've discussed with six
Sheriff Arpaio and now the idea that you
have I think it's 15 states and district
alone via filing a lawsuit saying that
because 78 percent of these young people
are Mexican it's evidence of the
president's ongoing displeasure with
Mexicans and he's the one who's talked
about murderers and thieves he's the one
who said the judge who was a Mexican
heritage could not be a fairer arbiter
in his case so he has some history here
that loads the deck I don't know that it
applies to every Republican but I think
in this case people are saying hey
what's with Trump and these Mexicans why
is he have this kind of hard edge to him
people say well what is it really speaks
to his base today you had Maggie
Haberman of the New York Times it was
apparently well plugged in saying you
know he really didn't want to do it but
guess what Stephen Miller and who was a
used to work for Jeff Sessions he turned
general and it was an ally to Stephen
the famous phrase Napolitan bias there
you go that he wanted this but he saw
this as pleasing the Trump base that you
don't even have to do any winks and nods
you just do this and they say yeah you
go get them but the fact is that if it's
about jobs it's about the economy well
goodness gracious most corporate
executives and country are saying leave
this alone you have people saying you
know what most these kids contribute to
local economy they're good kids
and yet I don't know personnel Democrats
are siding with big business I like that
one where at any risk to the Democrats
making so much fuss about the plight of
illegal immigrants and not really
fighting for American jobs you've talked
about it I think I think it costs them
elections now they get they don't
realize that because the media is always
on their side so they think that they
have this false sense of belief they are
living in a bubble
as Scott Adams say they're living in a
different movie so they don't see how
they lost and meanwhile what you're
having is you have a President Obama who
rewarded uh people that were coming to
America but not people who were in
America and what Donald Trump lepton was
like he said all America it's not just
about them it's about all of us that was
a winning vision to the interior point I
always am always troubled by the thing
about the judge like he said the judge
was a Mexican so he can't but jus who
does that
lawyers do that when they're picking a
jury when they're picking men and women
and blacks and whites and Hispanics
that's what he was doing what every
single lawyer does he looked at the
judges judge of Mexican you might not
like me that's what his that's that's
what lawyers do the lawyers do that and
he just did it and yet somehow it's
wrong so people grab these little
instances and they go oh he said this he
said this he said this but when you
actually focus on them they turn out to
be light as air about the way that's an
interesting point because President
Obama nominated a wise latina to the
Supreme Court just because he wanted
someone with that background and
background is that a CLE I want to talk
to Dana about a point you were just
making about the base for president
Trump Rush Limbaugh has some things to
say about that let's hear what he said
what Trump did today via sessions it's
it's almost along the same lines as
pulling out of the Paris Accords this is
just it's rocked them they didn't think
it would ever happen Trump is not dis
callous shroomish duck dis cold-hearted
but Trump knows his base and he knows
the impact all of this has had on the
American economy and American jobs and
he's following through on one of his
most predominant campaign commitments
how would you assess that well all true
and then at 8:38 p.m. last night which
is after that show aired President Trump
tweeted that he's good with keeping daca
so like in the morning Jeff Sessions
said it's hundreds of thousands of jobs
have been lost because of this and we
have to do something that we have to
have to deal with it and then not 12
hours later I guess that's moot because
he wants to have a legislative solution
which I'm for a legislative solution as
well I do think there's a possibility of
this Congress has been
closed on comprehensive or whatever we
want to call it immigration reform for
many years like over ten years probably
three or four times but the thing that's
different now is that there is now a
deadline so it's six months okay so a
deadline can focus the mind and it is
possible that you might figure out a way
to do it what I would have done if I
were Schumer and Pelosi today when the
president agreed with them on the the
debt relief bill I would have said while
we're at it sir
we would propose a straight up or down
vote on Dhaka on Friday we got the votes
you say you want it
they say that we've got the votes how
about a deal there are enough there a
job done it worked that up here's if
they get it off the table here's the
thing about what jeff Sessions said and
this is what I take issue with whenever
there's a logical fallacy falling from a
politician's lips I'm always dubious
that you know he said that hundreds of
thousands of jobs have been taken by
these dreamers and that's my problem and
liberal self or suffer from this mostly
it's a new strain within the Republican
Party and that's the idea that economics
is a zero-sum game we know it isn't we
know that you can actually create more
wealth you can create more jobs you can
create more opportunity in this country
for everybody you just have to let the
economy go and get the government out of
the West / - wait wait let me just say
the one thing first - Greg it's illegal
for a lawyer to make a selection jury
selection based on race they can have
exemptions where they don't have to
explain it right but it's illegal to say
that because of someone's raised Harrod
or whatever it that's so that you know
they do that's just not true great the
second thing to say here is that Sarah
Huckabee Sanders said oh you know what
President Trump wants a total fix he
wants comprehensive immigration reform
plus daca
so basically then he's sending it back
to Congress and saying oh well I guess
the odds are against it's happening but
I'm going to claim that oke it's a
legitimate place to do it so he creates
anxiety fear in this community of young
people who have jobs high-percentage
almost 80% working paying taxes
contributing to local economies he puts
them on edge and nobody says hey you
know what why are you playing politics
with this and then speaking of muddling
whole issue of is this comprehend
immigration reform or do you really want
doc not ugly playing politics though why
won't Democrats admit that it was a
horrible idea on the part of President
Obama if they would stand up and say
this was a bad idea in the first place
that set up the situation well you know
Dianne Feinstein said it last night that
we played it just in case anybody wants
a refresher